[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You've made
it to the last lab in the quest.
After you complete
this lab on Quiklabs,
you'll finally
unlock your badge.
On this episode,
we're going to go over
what you'll learn in this
final lab, Google Genomics Quik
Start.
Google Genomics helps the
life science community
organize the world's
genomic information
and make it
accessible and useful.
Big genomic data is here today
with petabytes rapidly growing
towards exabytes.
Google Genomics is an API that
is part of the Google Cloud
Platform.
Through this and
other add-ons, you
can apply the same technologies
that power Google Search
and Maps to securely store,
process, explore, and share
large, complex data sets.
In this lab, you'll use
Google's implementation
of the htsget protocol and
SAMtools to create a project
and view some public
data for yourself.
To access genomic data stored
in Google Cloud Storage,
you can use Google's
implementation
of the htsget protocol,
defined by the Global Alliance
for Genomics and Health.
Google's htsget
implementation makes
it easy to access and share
data stored in your own cloud
projects without copying large
files to and from Compute
Engine virtual machines.
You can also use the htsget
server to access data
from public sources, like
Google's mirror of the 1,000
Genomes Project.
Is this it?
Is this the last
lab on your quest?
Congratulations.
We want to hear from you.
Tell us about your experience
following this Quiklabs quest,
and how you're
applying what you've
learned in your own applications
in the comments below.
We'll see you next month when
we embark on our next quest, GCP
Essentials.